hey uh what do you think has been the
difference the last five or six years
because I feel like Memphis as a whole
is like at the Forefront of hip-hop now
um and I feel like it was always there
and you guys were always very
influential on like what was happening
in Atlanta
um even like guys like Drake like uh but
in terms of like
Memphis is kind of like the city in rap
now
um
what would it like why do you think it's
fine it's finally y'all's time I guess
like and the rest of the industry is
obviously now everyone's signing people
from Memphis everyone's going to Memphis
like it's it's kind of crazy where you
guys are kind of like The Underdogs for
so long and now you guys are on top
and you guys obviously had a lot to do
with that you know
hey I love you eggs you need to start
with me
[Music]
yeah yeah
that's some real [ __ ] yeah
yeah I gave everybody like I ain't gonna
say I made every like all the everybody
my age and younger rap but I gave them
the confidence to go ahead and you know
what I'm saying I gave them
a little bit more boost to their ego too
you know what I'm saying be like oh yeah
glocking dude I know I for sure can you
know what I'm saying so it really what
it was if you asked me